uh excuse me but we need to talk about
our girl lizzo born Melissa Jefferson in
Detroit Michigan little is the
classically trained flutist be yourself
role model and pop star Prince Protege
who has captured the world's attention
with her Unapologetic talent and today
we're joined by lizzo guys 2022 let's
just call it the year of lizzo it is
time to catch up with lizzo where's my
watch it's bad [__] o'clock which means
I'm joined by the extremely talented one
and only lizzo she's also one of the
most famous vegans in the entertainment
industry and frequently shares her
unique plant-based recipes on social
media online I have been following lizzo
for a long time now and it's about damn
time I try some of her recipes myself
because let's be real that food looks
good as hell and I am here for it hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video I'll be eating like one
of my personal favorite pop stars lizzo
but you guys know the drill I'll be
dressing everything up Abby style and
turning it into hunger crushing combos
that I actually want to eat a quick
disclaimer that this diet is simply
compiled from random wedding a day
videos so I really cannot speak to its
accuracy of lizzo's legitimate diet not
that it matters because I'm only using
these meals as a template for teaching
judge nutrition and for inspiring what I
decide to make for myself this is just
what I ate on a random day and is not
meant to be copied or recommended as how
you should eat so always speak to a
registered dietitian about your unique
needs and of course if you guys are new
here don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen okay I
definitely identify as a lizzo fan like
the woman is a true star but like so
many modern day superheroes that aim to
shatter glass ceilings and pave a more
inclusive Road in the future live is no
stranger to online haters more
specifically lizzo has been bombarded
with fat phobic and racist attacks
online over the past few years you
cannot glorify obesity now it's like oh
that woman is 250 pounds good for her
and it's like
she's her own hero ah when what heroism
it is who is overweight and black oh my
God it's everyone's fault that I'm fat
but mine it's white people's fault it's
men's fault it's not because of her
genetics it's because she chooses to
love herself and overeat to the point of
dramatically shortening her life but
she's also made it known that she does
not need anyone to fight her battles
sharing exactly how she feels when it
comes to trolls they'd be like lizzo why
don't you clap back why don't you clap
back cause [__] I'm winning home and I
know I'm great and I'm happy but even
happy people you know I'm saying I
strive for joy every single day the girl
always claps back with precision and her
unbothered let him talk kind of attitude
and honestly we love a confident Queen
but I also want to quickly note that
lizzo is also human and as I discussed
in my video right here the media labeled
lizzo the body positive poster child
because she was simply larger bodied not
necessarily because it was the identity
that she saw for herself which of course
opened her up to even more criticism
when she makes healthy or even diet
culturally choices I'm not gonna go too
far into that because I actually did a
deep dive in my previous video but today
I'm going to take a stab at eating like
our girl okay I'm not gonna lie I'm
already feeling slightly overwhelmed and
exhausted thinking about all the cooking
in this day I'm sure I could take some
shortcuts but I also just feel like
lizzo has such amazing amazing
plant-based recipe inspiration on her
Tick Tock I couldn't do her dirty I have
to go all out so it's gonna be a long
day on my feet I'm probably not gonna
get a whole lot else accomplished today
but I am excited to learn some new
recipes so lizzo let's talk breakfast so
I didn't see a whole lot online about
lizzo's coffee regimen but I did see her
drink coffee out of a ridiculously small
little coffee mug on CBS This Morning so
you know
we got our own now as her food I have
watched a lot of tick tock content lizzo
specifically and a lot of her wedding
days usually start with like some kind
of fresh fruit which is great we love
fruit I know she's into pomegranates
which is great because we're actually in
season right now when we're filming this
and I also watched her hop on that whole
like nature cereal bandwagon well let's
take a look
trying the coconut water Berry breakfast
cereal I like ice with my cereal
and
[Music]
oh it's good I'll be I mean listen I
love fruit I eat fruit every day at
breakfast and snacks but fruit with
coconut water is not cereal hard stuff
it sounds delicious but calling it
cereal insinuates that it's a clear
replacement for whole grain cereal when
it's literally just fruit and calling it
Nature's cereal insinuates that actual
cereal is somehow unnatural not clean
not nutritious or wholesome and I want
to be clear that lizzo didn't make this
stupid Trend up or name it so I'm really
not calling her out for it she was
literally just trying out a tick tock
Trend like so many other people do but
whoever did create Nature's cereal know
that words matter and the trend of
trying to replace normal foods with like
super low calorie foods and call them
equivalent is really getting old can we
put that one to bed now so we're gonna
make real cereal but of course keep it
plant-based so one way I love to just
bump up protein in a basic bowl of
cereal is to essentially make the milk
like a little protein shake so I just
throw in some protein
add my milk
and I know it's controversial that I'm
adding the milk basically before the
cereal but you have to do this step
otherwise you're going to get clumps
a little frothy Frost I need to mix my
cereals because I cannot just have one
okay oh my goodness
so puffins
handful of that crispix guys do you
remember crispix
I recently found it at the grocery store
again and I was just like holy sh the
crunch factor is out of control it's so
light so crispy I mean not a ton of
nutrition but whatever I I like it so
that's my base gonna add in some fruit
and some banana
and maybe just like a little sprinkle
of
you know the good stuff
okay breakfast part one done this would
be delicious but just not enough for me
personally so I also know that Liz is a
big fan of this kind of just egg product
you can get it in like liquid
um vegan eggs or you can get this just
already made which I was like yes please
one last pan to dirty especially in the
morning I am here for that so apparently
you just put this in the microwave for
one and a half minutes all right I can
do that so I'm just gonna makeshift like
a little breakfast wrap situation I got
some avocado which was looking a bit
beautiful so smash that bad boy down
actually you know what maybe we can just
leave them got some baby tomatoes
see these are the kind of meals that I
don't mind making
um it's when I have to dirty up a pot or
pan that I get a little a little salty
uh okay so do we unfold this or do we
just keep it as is I'm just gonna guys
help me out it's too hot to unfold so if
we're just gonna leave it like that my
favorite Curry ketchup
a little bit of heat a little bit of
sweet
thank you very much you know what let's
get a toothpick we're gonna improvise
guys
we're gonna improvise
nice
all right we have protein in our protein
powder plus our hemp hearts and in the
just egg I was actually pretty impressed
one of those little just egg patties has
I think like seven grams of protein
pretty awesome uh we've got healthy fats
in our hemp seeds and our avocado carbs
in our cereal and our wrap and of course
tons of fiber with all the fruits and
veg I'm personally more excited about
the cereal situation because I'm a sweet
breakfast girl but I feel like I need to
blow this out before I'm eating wax all
morning so happy birthday
to someone
huh
the roast egg tastes like egg they look
really good
um
foreign
okay folks we got some fuel in the tank
now it's time to get some joyful
movement in and not only is our girl
lizzo a boss in the kitchen but the
fitness singer is also a beast in the
gym and while I don't want to paint
lizzo as like the good fatty who
exercises in juxtaposition with the bad
fatty who doesn't it is worth pointing
out that a person's body shape or size
does not indicate their Fitness level or
their engagement in physical activity
Abby can you elaborate a bit but also
like not too much because it's a lot
yeah Abby it is a lot and the last thing
I want to do is to get into an in-depth
discussion about being overweight or
obese and health outcomes nor do I want
to see any comments about lizzo or me
glorifying obesity because that
discussion is well beyond what we can
unpack here in this video today ain't
nobody got time for that but I want to
say that the Healthcare Community feels
pretty strongly that BMI is is not the
sole or key indicator of health and
being classified as obese doesn't
automatically denote poor health in fact
a review of the literature found that
exercise is actually more important than
weight loss or dieting especially if
you're in that overweight or obese
category when it comes to lowering your
risk of heart disease or premature death
that is key I haven't seen lizzo's Labs
but she probably trains way harder than
I ever could to like pull off her
Marathon style Rockstar performances
good luck Abby thanks so I'm not in a
particularly energetic mood it is Monday
while I am filming this but there are so
many clips of lizzo working out online
and she's got quite a range in
activities that she enjoys so sometimes
I've seen her do like a hit workout with
some floor work in there or she does
like the ropes and dumbbells and she
also told Women's Health magazine that
she loves to get her heart rate up with
jump rope and apparently she also loves
snowy weather hikes in Canada here we
prefer to call that just like getting
from point A to point B in a winter
storm
foreign
but I figure we could do a few of
lisso's favorite moves and call it a day
let's do it
[Music]
I am ready for Alyssa lunch and
according to our Tick Tock the girl
loves her veg she's often seen either
eating or making different kinds of
salads and has become famous for her
viral Tick-Tock Green Goddess salad it's
definitely an unconventional salad I
would never have thought to put this
together myself so I'm really really
excited to try it out so while I get
chopping up some veg Abby can you go
over like salad and diet culture for us
please you got it girl so lizzo has been
labeled the poster child of the body
positivity movement despite probably
never asking for that title as I
discussed in my video right here but
regardless she has been vocal about
eating intuitively and honoring her
body's needs with the foods that she
actually truly enjoys and despite what
our fat phobic Society will tell you
larger body people eat salads too also
just because we choose to eat salad or a
vegetable doesn't mean we're actively
trying trying to change our bodies when
we're most attuned with our body's needs
it often will tell us like hey like a
cell would be really awesome right now
so this is a reminder that dye culture
doesn't own salad it doesn't own healthy
food You Don't Own Me and you aren't
succumbing to diet Culture by enjoying
these Foods love that and honestly when
I started to learn how to eat
intuitively one of the biggest
Revelations for me was that I actually
love salad it's not a punishment for me
it's something that I just actually
intuitively crave and that's what
happens when you let go of this whole
good food bad food mentality eating
salad doesn't need to be a punishment
for eating a cupcake but anyways let's
talk about what we got here we have
chopped up a ton of cabbage just a basic
green cabbage this is a great salad by
the way if you are trying to save money
because I know veg is so expensive and a
head of cabbage will feed a family of
like 12 for like a whole week maybe not
quite but pretty close so I'm gonna
throw some of that in there we've got a
couple cucumbers here little baby cukes
that I've just done a similar size mince
and then some green onions
for a lot of great flavor all right I
don't want to script the dressing even
though I'm pretty sure that lizzo also
just kind of freestyled it which is my
style but I'm going to kind of watch her
as a guide to make sure I don't forget
anything okay okay time to make the
dressing what's a person from Boston's
favorite book Charlotte's Web oh my God
hilarious
oh okay let's make some noise
smell like garlic for days okay lime
I also like lines better
oh oh erase my vinegar hers looked dark
what kind of rice wine vinegar was that
okay just a little
dude
I ate walnuts Okay Okay girl okay
slow it down now okay we got the cashews
on for the mouth
walnuts
basil
spinach
avocado oil okay let's just
it's going too fast
stems off spinach
okay
avocado oil
I think we're gonna need a lot
this is probably not going to blend so
well
lots of that
okay salt and pepper
might be peppery feels chaotic
but
I think she's gonna work I measured this
with my Sean does so let's see how it
come out
[Music]
okay lizzo just said say that she added
some water and I do think we're gonna
have to do the same just a touch
smells really good
okay let me just taste it for seasoning
what a sweet that I put in there
this is really good
[Music]
okay lizzo fans I know this is delicious
I know it's probably Perfection all on
its own but your girl needs a little
protein in the lunch so I have
foreign
it's going to add a crunch oh it's like
a crouton we love that it's like a
higher protein Crouton oh and it adds
just like a little bit of color as well
all right I'm super jazzed about this
we've got tons of fiber in our cabbage
here and our veg plus some chickpea
action as well I've got protein the
chickpeas and the nutritional yeast and
lots of healthy fats in the walnuts and
the cashews and the avocado oil plus
some carbs on the side for good measure
it looks amazing and super satiating
these chips are just not woman enough to
stand up to the salad all right let's
try this again oh
I think it needs to marinate a little
longer
very carefully okay I'm just gonna give
it some extra
emotional support here
there you go
um
[Music]
oh
yes
yes nailed it
um
I love you [__]
oh you get it you see what you did there
all right got a little work done now
it's time for a snack so according to a
ton of lizzo's videos some of lizzo's
go-to snacks are chocolate a protein
shake fruit with peanut butter or bubble
tea lots of great choices here love that
for us bubble tea
I know unpopular opinion it's a no for
me I just I can't get over the feeling
of like sucking gelatinous balls into my
mouth
so why don't we do a little like fruit
chocolate peanut butter combo and I know
lizzo is big on bananas so I think we're
gonna make some little peanut butter
chocolate banana bites a little bit of
peanut butter right down this is
optional but you guys know
put that on everything add its little
meat BFFs for life
and then I just do like a half dip
well like even that oh it's hard to keep
them together
plop them down
all right we're gonna pop these into the
freezer for about 20 to like 30 minutes
or so just until they're set up and then
we'll have a snack
one eternity later
she's ready
look at these cuties and you can pick
like a huge batch of these and then just
keep them in the freezer when you need a
little something something at the end of
the day as we do now so check it out we
got healthy fats protein and fiber in
our hemp hearts and our peanut butter
pull out some carbs in our banana and
some chocolate for good measure
tastes like ice cream with that texture
look at that
so silky so good I am hungry the kids
are hungry let's talk about dinner so
according to all the tick tocks that
I've watched I find that lizzo tends to
gravitate towards kind of like heartier
kind of home style meals when it comes
to dinner which is great it is winter
time that's my style as well so I've
seen videos of her making like Korean
style rice cakes and a really delicious
looking sauce there's one here of
plant-based enchiladas we love that and
also like a veggie curry with rice and
plantain patties I love this I like
lizzo's Diet is so beautifully varied no
one can look at this plant-based diet
and claim that they are not getting
enough variety and I actually hear from
a lot of vegans and vegetarians that
exploring different cultural Cuisines
has become a lot more kind of standard
practice for them and obviously we're so
lucky that here in 2023 there are so
many kind of like faux plant-based
options that kind of mimic or emulate
classic traditional North American
animal based food but additionally there
are a lot of cultures out there that
don't rely as heavily on kind of
animal-based foods so a lot of Asian
Indian or Latin American Cuisines for
example lean on a lot of naturally
plant-based Foods just traditionally and
I love that I get to benefit from this
inspiration and exploration as well and
also just kind of make my family
something that maybe I otherwise
wouldn't have thought of so I think
we're gonna go with the enchiladas
because my kids love kind of like
Mexican style food but I admittedly
really haven't experimented much with
Jackfruit as a non-vegan Abby can you
give us a Lowdown and explain why we're
using fruit in an enchilada you got it
girl so I actually really enjoyed the
texture of jackfruit in both sweet and
savory dishes and I know the vegan
Community loves it for its undeniable
shape-shifting abilities to mimic pulled
pork or chicken it's also rich in
vitamin C potassium calcium B vitamins
and iron plus it boasts two and a half
grams of fiber the downside is that
there's less than three grams of protein
per serving so if we want to bump up
that's a tidy factor I would recommend
adding another protein Source you got it
girl I'm gonna put my Abby spin on this
to just bump up the protein a little bit
so I got some tempeh and some
nutritional yeast I'm gonna throw in
there but I'm actually kind of excited
about this pseudo enchilada recipe
because it's kind of a lazy girl's
version like you don't even have to roll
the enchiladas which I love it's more of
just kind of a layered casserole so easy
we're gonna pan fry some tortillas and
get cooking
all right I think this one's good
I just want a little toasty
nice
a little more oil because she's spicy
got our jackfruit
this is going to add the texture but not
a whole lot in the protein Department
so I got some tempeh here
I figured we could add some extra veg so
I've got some bell pepper
and because we've got cabbage for days
might as well throw a little of that in
there
all right a little salt
a little pep and because I've been
cooking all day I got some enchilada
sauce green chili baby
so much easier
just because I like extra cheesy flavor
plus some B12 and protein I'm gonna
throw some nooch in there
now we load her up
get my arm workout in
[Music]
I got some plant-based cheese and we
need lots of it obviously
and you know what I feel like this could
use it's a little pickled jalapenos what
do you say let's do it
um gotta get some of that juice in there
too let's pop her into the oven and
let's get that cheese melted so I kind
of love this take on an enchilada
because it's literally like a plate of
nachos but for dinner we love that
I'm gonna top mine
with a little
pico de gallo
and guacamole
and a little cilantro don't know how to
eat this but I figure it's all going to
the same place we've got some carbs in
our tortilla we've got lots of fiber in
all the veg and the Jackfruit that I
added in there we've got some healthy
fats in our guacamole and we've got some
protein in the nutritional yeast and the
tempeh I added
[Music]
mmm
that is so so good the green chili sauce
she just had Steph wrap
all right let's finish the day with
something sweet so according to our
interview with Gail King lizzo's
favorite food of all time is plantains
she even made the plantain sandwich
completely go viral on Tick Tock which
is a recipe that I still need to try but
today we're gonna do them sweet and I
hear that lizzo loves them with kind of
like sweet cream so we're gonna do them
lizzo style and of course keep them
vegan let's do it all right little
coconut oil a little coconut sugar
we're gonna make like a vegan caramel
basically
and I got my plantains
I'm gonna kind of put them down like
this and get coated in that caramelae
um
already smells so good
literal candy right here and plantain is
actually packed with fiber plus we got
some vitamin C action I'm gonna throw on
a little coconut whipped cream
and
lime zest
a little drizzle of dark chocolate
and some toasted coconut for some
healthy fats and delicious tropical
flavor
so crispy so good
this is my kind of dessert that is good
as hell guys I loved this day I mean I
haven't had plantains since like my last
holiday and that was a huge fun bonus I
had some delicious kind of easy cheater
enchiladas which really took me no time
to pull off and I learned the salad
recipe that I'm Legit going to be making
on the weekly especially with the price
of veg right now cabbage is our friend
so guys I hope you enjoyed this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
Whose diet you'd like to see me attempt
next subscribe to the channel and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
thank you